[Music]
in swing city news swing like my thing
is for married couples [ __ ] yeah see
remember we never did it we should do it
I can do some swing moves yeah shall we
have to throw Niki ronke back a new
swing moves - but your swing well
they're still practicing Ben and Ed she
was gonna do almost beheaded on that
Jerry laughs dad I'm really good at
swinging it's like one two three one two
three back step one two three you wanted
the politics of Swing I always just did
good swing you don't say I never played
the politics like that we should go to
kyndra's studio and this side up for
classes everyone have can I take salsa
but by them saying I don't know it makes
me feel good well I think they're just
so good at everything else
well I think that jokes gonna fail just
because they know you and they're gonna
be like oh he's [ __ ] around
what that's the ultimate punch line
yeah you can kick ass and you run out of
jokes you just beat someone up most
violent places on me yeah you don't
laugh at their jokes they jump in the
crowd and start punching submitted by a
magic booty 4:08 hey buddy buddy the
parlor
hey that's like an Oakland booty with
the LA face
I think so no I think that's five 100
408 San Jose I think okay I [ __ ] it up
San Jose II more than 1000 swingers will
flock Las Vegas if so could be that
swinger I don't know what swingers
though pretty good guys it's the married
couple [ __ ] 1000 singers will flock
to Las Vegas for the world's biggest
orgy oh [ __ ] I tell y'all I kind of want
to do something like this but yeah yeah
but in mines Oh with close friends only
we don't all agree but in my Hey was a
big day and he'll give you an experience
I can never get me
that's why oh yeah that's true you sure
did yeah her first was a big dick she
told us she had one of these guys what
still peekaboo comes up finds cover I
forgot she kept thinking about that big
I do but in my type of orgy everyone has
to wear a mask but everyone has to be a
[ __ ] model like everyone has been you
can't be invited it's my it's my fantasy
this is the shortest video ever
no she's just gonna pull up the [ __ ]
airlock
my confidence is through the roof even
though when he said that I was like well
it's still my fantasy but you I can't
hear you because you're in space right
now cuz he just [ __ ] lost you in
outer space
I thought he was like you can't be
invited because orgies are all ugly
people but I get oh right it's a joke
stop flirting
yeah [ __ ] piss you can also give an
experience I can give ya know what they
saying yeah but everyone was just a
[ __ ] model and then I'll be like the
butt ugly one are you happy [ __ ]
happy hey papito
I guess can I come to this orgy yeah
yeah yeah it would be us too oh so she's
calling you I'm not gonna wear a mask no
would you be fine if bar was like [ __ ]
another chicks if she's fine as [ __ ]
like it everyone's fine but how do you
know if there's a mask over there oh
there's some really good part because
when they're wearing a mask I get to see
only their eyes oh you know you don't
mean the like the blindfolded man yeah I
mean this mask yeah what their face is
all like I don't care the mask makes
them look I like the masquerade ball man
in your mind it's just the body yeah
that needs to be muscled and whatever I
can see it just has to be like
symmetrical on point perfect skin okay
no hair huh what about three but pimples
no but pimples what about a [ __ ] stamp
why would that me even matter is that
that makes me go Jews are fine I'm fine
with the tribal one thing about like
trash to those tribals dope you know
we've got so excited everyone's talking
over each other did you do it orgy no
even with my scenario my scenario what
about you well Casey doesn't have to be
there [ __ ] oh people yeah it's Ryan
Gosling his brother his cousin everyone
it's all the guys along I know it can
feel
fun I know I was like it would be fun
until I saw Steve [ __ ] a girl that
I'd be pissed yeah it's the same like if
I see KC literally I'm like no he's mine
but they're like I did [ __ ] but you
can't [ __ ]
yo see I'm so territorial over her that
though this would never happened
just never happened how GOI any more
dicks around me I don't want dudes on
her I don't want chicks on her
I don't want anybody on her but me yeah
I think I'm down through all right so
anyway I know you're down what the [ __ ]
I joke I been to an orgy club that when
it was happening but remember I deejay
for a birthday party
oh you're in a building they used to
have an orange inside it is an orgy club
yeah it's a secret club and to make
extra income they were letting people
like rent it for parties and stuff
that's on that KC films yeah the whole
place was just straight beds and beds
and beds and like crazy couch isn't
[ __ ] everything dude so much sure
they were Niki run a place that hosted
orgies - yeah remember weird oh yeah it
was like a sex parties they call them
but like where you could it was like a
normal party where you could have drinks
and stuff but then like if you wanted to
go [ __ ] yous there's like places - fine
we were not a sex party we were at the
bill we were at the house of the guy
that has the sex party so there's like
sex swings and stuff yeah you just look
around like we're interviewing the guy
for something well because it was like
about how people have adult parties yeah
it was interesting not to come all over
the place yeah we didn't know I was on
the swing I didn't even know was a sex
swing I was just like getting my makeup
done on the swing and it was like okay
no like you didn't tell us before we
came over like this is a sex dungeon
they were just like they were gonna
shoot a thing so you were like oh cool
they just have random swings it looks
good athletically I like I would have
this in my house it was an all leather
inches no no it was like nice looking
like like modern Oh Nicki's at IKEA
she's like you guys had the [ __ ] swing
no
Oh which reminds me everything you would
do to dots on top hotel like the
drive-up hotels look like they had in
Mexico I don't know if they have them
here but in Mexico they have these
drive-up hotels where you people just go
and they rent them by the hour and my
friends and I we went there after
clubbing or whatever but they did have a
Jacuzzi in the middle of the room but I
didn't know that they it was a sex hotel
I was young understand and they did have
a sec sweetie I remember swinging on
that now it just you reminded me oh [ __ ]
I hope you took a shower
whoa long Candis crazy because when you
order room service there's this window
like this is it this big no no no it's
like this big in it turn huh like a
dumbwaiter
I don't know what that is oh it's like
or you open it and then like so Oh kind
of like that but instead of going down
or up or whatever it's this way oh so
just rotate so you never happens the
other person yeah crazy anyway this
story here that's crazy yeah so there's
this organization called menage life and
it's for sexually free people and
they're organizing this huge event
that's gonna be held in Las Vegas on
June 2nd they're gonna be trying to
break the record for the largest orgy in
human history they're gonna do it inside
of a convention space inside of the
Embassy Suites that's too many bodies I
just don't like crowds yeah they have an
orgy if it's not crowded okay are not
standards for me but what if it's a huge
like let's say it's like a basketball
court like that big and then there's you
know people are kind of spread out and
you can walk around and stuff yeah
depends on how many people are invited I
picture it being like that Britney
Spears slave for you video where there's
a lot even alike
that be private I'd be done with that
but if they all look like that though
the bodies all have to be like that I
think it look like a basket full of
maggots that's exactly what that video
looks like it's a nude beach people nude
beaches Maggie not just oh I don't know
I mean like dating 10,000 beautiful
people into one spot it's gonna be very
difficult but there are beautiful people
I'm down to sacrifice myself I mean
they'll be that'd be ideal but I feel
like it's gonna be ten thousand people
at Walmart you're a hundred percent
correct so they're anticipating more
than a thousand people for this event so
the previous record for the largest or
do is five hundred people but so they're
trying to double it how do you how do
you [ __ ] someone in an orgy like okay
like if I want [ __ ] Jill and Miss orgy
oh I think you're thirty it's really
given if you if you're if you're in this
room that's it it's a free-form yeah but
do you like each other they're like some
type of etiquette because like what if
you're like doing doggy style and then
you you pull out to rest and a guy comes
over and goes my turn
oh wait who's eating mass Oh chicks eat
Amaya that's cool yeah yeah yeah that's
cool oh my god what if like you pull
your dick out alright the guy comes out
of nowhere sucks your dick and it's the
best blow job you ever had you know I
can't argue with what do you do I think
I think you just enjoy yourself
I think after I retract my statement cuz
in my fantasy I'm like the queen getting
serviced and I call upon who I want but
now with that like I lose even my ass
you're just enjoying it right and this
girl just sits on your face I brought
you back to earth I'm picturing like a
rumble street fight but sexually I guess
we'd have to do is put your back against
the wall so that doesn't happen to you
yeah and what if you get intercepted
like you're like oh yeah like her and
you start walking over and then as soon
as you walk over some girl grabs your
dick and pulls you this way you start
sucking it yeah and another guy comes
and eats your ass you're like think
about if it was the end of the world
that we all know like there was a meteor
coming we're all gonna die but you're
like at a baseball game or something but
you're in a stadium I feel like everyone
should just [ __ ] cuz I want to go out
[ __ ] like I want to like having sex
in it and enjoying the moment so I
wonder like I feel like that's the only
situation where I'd be ok just like
straight up [ __ ] around a crowd of
people yeah all the meteors coming I
don't think I can get hard because I'd
be too scared yeah
anyway too scary yeah we gotta go we
gotta go out like we can't control it
Hey look you're the chick though you
don't have to stay hard like that
someone else it gets really small give
me stressful when you're like in a
stressful situation yeah but I'm saying
you gotta let it go cuz like you don't
have control over it maybe you're gonna
die [ __ ] but you can't control your
body when you can get out of the
situation and that's stressful cuz
you're like I gotta find a way to get
out well you don't have that updated
control over this it's a meteor it's
gonna hit you you're gonna die so just
[ __ ] let's the spunk it's like we're
trying to reason with me and I'm like
uh-huh I'll reason with your day
hey how about you suck my dick can get
hard Shh drink this alcohol for your
brain and then give me your dick okay
she knows
[Music]